[Applaudissements]
papa tu gagnais combien d'argent quand
tu étais sur canal plus bas suffisamment
pour me faire arrêter par papy aux
chercheurs mais jouer j'ai trouvé un
sachet d'herbe qui traînent dans le
tiroir de ta chambre c'est quoi comme
airbus et de la tisane ma fille c'est
qui la dame qui vient de voir
l'après-midi dans la chambre comme un
mojito travail et m'a serrée
si j'ai déjà décollé à l'école la
maîtresse a parlé de françois hollande
c'est qui exactement eu quelqu'un qui
aime bien les gens comme les b sens dans
papa comment on fait les bébés
bah je prends une blantyre à ma fille
mais la passe est un jour normal
banon me 38 fatouaki la toi qui l'a vu
en plein combat
non mais sérieux elle s'appelle comment
votre vie angelina au l'ombre à son
génie dawa jud aussi appelé el gringo
cruellement dans tes trucs qu'on voit là
c'est lui qui parle comme ça
c'est que ces gens ne te voir dans la
vie de tous les jours en famille ça doit
être génial le maire le mec c'est
n'annoncez pas contre quillan fait je ne
sais pas de sa fierté cela dit je veux
une image et là une belle image un peu
mystique qui parle de potasse et finit
avec une tasse de thé ou café dans le
cul
il parlait pas et on disait c'est un bon
joueur ça va changer de slip